JOHN: Hi, guys, I'm
John [INAUDIBLE].
I'm here from the
YouTube marketing team.
I'm so excited to be here with
Leap Motion CEO and co-founder
Michael Buckwald.
And before we get
started, I just
want to explain what
this space is all about.
Obviously we're in
the distribute section
of the sandbox, and we're
all about talking about
once the product is
designed and developed,
how do you get it out there?
How do you distribute it?
And Michael in here on hand,
after building an amazing piece
of technology, to talk about
how he did that, the struggles
he faced, and what advice
we could get out of that.
So Michael, I'm super
excited to have you here.
MICHAEL BUCKWALD:
Very happy to be here.
JOHN: Awesome.
I got to tell you, when
I heard we confirmed you,
I feel like my inner like
science fiction fan came out,
because, like, the technology
that you're making--
and I'll let you talk about
instead of me [INAUDIBLE].
I feel like you're
bringing that to life,
and just breaking all frontiers.
So why don't you
tell us a little bit
about what Leap
Motion is all about.
What does it do.
MICHAEL BUCKWALD:
Well, Leap Motion
is about tracking hands
and fingers in space
very accurately,
and in a way that
can be applied to anything
that has a computer.
So we want people
to feel like they
are reaching through
their computer screen,
reaching into the digital
world, and doing things
like molding a piece of
clay with their fingers,
grabbing a ball and throwing it.
All the things that
we're able to do
with the physical
world around us,
making those possible in the
same easy, accessible way
than we have interacted
with the physical world
our entire lives.
JOHN: Awesome.
Awesome.
And let's just talk about
how it looks tactically.
It's a physical, little device
that goes below-- it plugs
into your USB.
Can you talk about
how the looks, so we
get just a clear idea
of what Leap Motion is?
MICHAEL BUCKWALD: Yeah,
so the first product
based on the technology is
the Leap Motion controller,
which we're selling for $79.
And it's a small lighter
or pack-of-gum sized device
that connects via
USB to a computer
and turns the area
around the computer
into a 3D interaction space,
so that you can use your hands
and fingers above the device
to control the computer.
JOHN: Yeah, it's fascinating.
And I'm just curious-- how
many people in the audience
and heard about
Leap Motion before?
Awesome.
So new technology is
really pushing the ground.
Some people say that it may make
the keyboard, the mouse a thing
of the past.
I know perhaps you're
trying to think
about it as a
complementary, or thinking
about those things evolving.
But have you ever had a
moment where you thought
that the product was
perhaps [INAUDIBLE]
ahead of what
consumers are used to?
And how have you
adapted to that?
MICHAEL BUCKWALD: I think the
way that we think about it is,
in terms of a five
or ten year journey.
So our goal has always been to
transform how people interact
with computers, and for us that
means not just the PC, but also
transforming how people
interact with their car,
or their TV, their VR
headset, their mobile device,
and computers and form factors
that don't exist today at all.
And we're starting with
the PC, and for the PC,
it isn't about replacing
the mouse or keyboard-- it's
about doing all the
things that you just
can't do well with
the mouse or keyboard.
But we don't really think of
ourselves as early or late,
it's about bringing
a motion control
to the world, one
market at a time,
over a significant
period of time.
Probably five or ten years.
JOHN: And what-- I know you
mentioned those pain points.
What do you think Leap
Motion is helping push past?
What is Leap Motion
helping to made easier
by changing the form factor of
interacting with your computer?
MICHAEL BUCKWALD: Yeah, the
inspiration for the technology
goes back to a problem
that my co-founder David
Holz-- he's our CTO-- realized
six or seven years ago.
Which is that even though a
small child can build something
out of Play-Doh that kind
of looks like a coffee
cup in minutes, a professional
3D modeler takes a half hour
to do the same thing.
Or an hour to the same thing.
And that wasn't because
computers aren't powerful,
because everyone
in this room has
a processor in
their pockets that's
more powerful than a
supercomputer was 15 years ago.
It's not because
people aren't creative.
It's because there's
a barrier between us
and our computers,
and technology.
And that barrier
are input devices,
like mice and
keyboards, which are
binary-- you are
pushing the x button
or you're not
pushing the x button.
You're clicking the
left mouse button,
not clicking the
left mouse button.
And if you compare that to an
action, like grabbing a cup
and drinking from it, that's
incredibly complex action,
but we do things like that
thousands of times a day.
We're successful
100% of the time.
And it's completely
thoughtless for us.
And because we've evolved
an almost magical ability
to use our hands and
fingers to interact
with the physical world.
And that's what we want
to bring to computers.
So that someone can see a piece
of clay, see a physical object,
reach in, and because they
already know how to do that,
they can be doing
something like 3D model
that they never would
have been able to do
with the keyboard, and
mouse, and drop-down menus,
and instruction books,
and keyboard shortcuts.
JOHN: Right.
That's awesome.
And I think a lot
of developers have
seen the value of what you're
trying to do with Leap Motion.
I know we were touching
on it the other day,
and you mentioned that there's
over 100,000 developers
currently trying to build
on the Leap Motion platform.
How do you get to the
community around the product,
and did you have that
mindset from day one,
or is that just
something that evolved?
MICHAEL BUCKWALD: Yeah.
We've always wanted developers
to be on the platform.
And we have to focus on making
great tracking technology
and building great
tools for developers,
but we can't possibly create
all of the experiences
or tackle all the problems
where Leap Motion is valuable.
Because the technology
this has implications
that are as diverse
as casual games
to surgeons in
the operating room
and professional engineers.
And so we absolutely have always
wanted to empower developers
to do great things
with platform,
and today as you said, there
are about 100,000 developers
in over 100 countries that
are using the device to
and do really,
really interesting--
that makes us feel great.
JOHN: And can take me
through, because I'm trying
sit in the shoes of a
lot of I/O attendees,
maybe you have a
product out there,
platform where developers
are trying to build on it.
How did you, from day
one, go from one developer
to 100,000 developers?
Like, how did you-- did
you reach out to them,
did they hear about the product
and were so passionate about it
and wanted to develop it?
How did that process
happen for somebody
who's trying to get their first
developer on their platform,
let's say?
MICHAEL BUCKWALD: Yeah,
it's a great question.
And I think that the
biggest thing was the fact
that people are excited about
and really care about this.
And like you said, the reason
that so much of science fiction
for such a long time
has talked about
and depicted new
interfaces-- I think
it does reflect this sort
of subconscious realization
that-- or conscious
realization-- that we need more
with computers, and that it
is the input and the interface
that is holding us back.
And I think that developers,
more than most people,
realize that as well.
So I think there is just
this intrinsic excitement
to being able to build
something truly new,
and solve problems
that are fundamental.
Like, what is the best way
to build an application where
someone is interacting
with the 3D model of Leap?
What's the best way to
build an application where
an elementary school child
learns by dissecting an animal?
What's the best way to build
something like a shooting game,
with motion control?
Those sorts of problems are not
tackled on a daily basis when
developing for other things, and
for some developers, that's not
attractive, but for many,
it's exciting and challenging,
and they get to be a part
of building foundations
that will help other
developers, as well.
But there are also little, but
very important things we do.
We work with developers
very closely,
and we attend events
all over the world
and show the
technology to people.
And we've devoted a lot
of energy to the SDK
and making it really easy
for people to develop.
And that's an ongoing journey.
There are many things
we are doing today,
and an infinite number of
things we can do in the future
to make it easier and
more accessible to people.
JOHN: Absolutely and in addition
to showcasing Leap's technology
at events around
the world, it sounds
like you're hosting events
at Leap Motion headquarters,
and bringing developers
in month by month
to help them interact
with your product.
Can you talk a little bit
about what these events are,
and how what exactly
happens at then
with the company
and the developers?
MICHAEL BUCKWALD:
One thing that I
think has been very successful
for us, besides attending
outside events, has been
to host our own meet-ups,
bring developers in, and
that gives us a chance
to speak a little bit
more informally with them
than we would at
big public events.
Or do things like blog
posts on social media
to show them what
we're working on
before we release
it to the public.
And we also do pretty
often bring developers
into our office
on a casual basis,
if we have a feature we want to
test, if we just want to talk,
or have a round table about the
SDK, or something like that,
we'll do that as well.
And that's really,
really helpful.
Ultimately, the people
whose entire lives-- or even
they're sort of a more amateur
or part-time developer--
the people who are
passionate about developing
on top of a platform,
they have so much
expertise from that focus.
So it's really important.
JOHN: That's fantastic.
So can you talk a little
bit more about your journey?
Are there any things
you wish you would've
done differently in distributing
Leap Motion technology doing
your early days?
Any mistakes that
we could learn from,
to avoid in and move on from?
MICHAEL BUCKWALD: Yeah, I mean
we've made a lot of mistakes,
we probably make
mistakes every day.
And what we're
trying to do, and I
think what anyone
trying to build
a platform and a fundamentally
new interface has to do,
is such a broad
challenge, that there
are countless ways they
will make mistakes.
Countless ways
we've made mistakes.
But I think the
most important thing
is to be really, really
focused on the core value
that technology brings.
And in our case, that is
the tracking and developers.
And making sure that you have
really strong relationships
with those developers.
And I think that as long
as people have that focus,
they will overcome
and sort of thrive
from the inevitable
mistakes that they'll make.
JOHN: Awesome.
Something else
that caught my eye
when we were talking
the other day
was, you mentioned that
you're in over 3,000 stores
and distributing Leap
Motion's technology.
Can you again take me
to the early days of,
who is the first store
that you partnered with?
How do you even get
that relationship going?
Because I know a
lot of people are
building amazing technology.
And the big thing
is, OK, I have it,
but how do I get
it out in stores?
How do I get it in
consumers' hands?
And I think you've
done such a great job,
both on the developer front
and the consumer front.
So if you could talk a
little bit about that,
that would be awesome.
MICHAEL BUCKWALD:
That's a great question.
When we launched
about a year ago,
our only retail
partner was Best Buy.
Which is a major retail
partner, and they
have about 1,000
stores in the U. S.,
but we had no international
retail presence,
and since then, we've had to
build out our own retail sales
team.
And we have to how people
in Europe and Japan
and China working
with retailers.
But today, we are in about
3,000 stores in '15 countries.
It is very challenging
to get retail.
And I think that maybe it
should be the primary focus,
because even before we were in
retail, the best thing we did
was take pre-orders
from customers.
And whether you do that through
traditional pre-orders that you
take on your
website, like we did,
or through some sort
of crowd funding,
I think that is the
best way to demonstrate
real, tangible, material
interest in the product,
and you can then take
that to retailers.
And that's very powerful.
That's probably, far and
away, the most efficient way.
And also, the
reality is that you
can build a successful business
with hardware, selling it
to customers through
your own website today.
And you could
certainly, that's how
we work with the
pre-order period,
but even after the
your own website can be a major
sales channel today in a way
it wasn't before.
So even if you can't
get retail, you
can still build a great business
selling a product directly
consumers.
JOHN: And so yeah, I think we've
seen a paradigm shift in how
commerces work, moving online.
So, in closing, I want
to ask one question,
and then I want to
open it up you guys
to be able to ask
questions of Michael,
any other last pieces of advice?
I'll preface this
with saying, no cliche
answers of how somebody can
get out there and distribute
their product.
Anything you learned
during your journey
that you want to share
here before we open it up
to the floor?
MICHAEL BUCKWALD: Well, I think
that the most important thing,
I'd say, is people shouldn't
be afraid to build hardware
products.
And I say that even though
we don't necessarily
think of ourselves, strictly
speaking, as a hardware
product, but even
today and there
is sort of this cloud
around hardware,
in the sense that it's too
expensive, or it's too hard,
or it takes too long.
But there are a lot
of real advantages
to building a hardware
product, and I think,
had we not chosen to first build
a peripheral before we tried
working with OEMs
like HP and others,
to embed the technology, I
think we'd still be here,
calling up people and trying
to convince them to embed it.
Because other people are slow
and OEMs are risk averse,
and I'm not going
to say have to,
but if you decide that you have
to own it yourself, and build
it entirely yourself, you
shouldn't be afraid to do that.
Because there is an incredible
ecosystem that exists today
they didn't necessarily
exist a few years ago.
And that makes it, not easy,
but possible for startups
to build hardware and
distribute it globally.
JOHN: Fantastic.
So it that, I think we're going
to take the mike from the back.
So if you guys have
questions, we can ask Michael.
So does anybody have a
question to ask Michael?
Nobody?
There you go.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Michael.
My question is, when you first
started to get the marketing
material out, how many
different forms of online media
did you use, because I
know, like, social media is
really important now.
So did you use all
mediums on social media,
or did you just use like,
content media online,
like through Google search?
MICHAEL BUCKWALD:
It's a great question.
And I think we've tried
to embrace all media.
I don't know if we've
quite succeeded,
because I think
one of the things
that we are still
developing, for example,
is having a bigger presence
in global social media.
But at least in terms of
the English-based social,
we've used pretty
much all the channels.
And I think you have to do that.
The cost to integrating
another social channel
is pretty low,
relative to the value,
assuming that it has a
sufficiently big audience.
And I think any platform
or anything that
is sufficiently different,
needs to reach out
to a lot of different people.
Like we want surgeons
to know about Leap,
but we want elementary school
teachers to know about Leap.
And that requires us
to reach out broadly.
So I think we've tried to
do that with media as well.
JOHN: So with that, I
just want to thank Michael
so much for his time, and thank
you guys for participating.
Thanks so much.
Awesome.
[APPLAUSE]